I I feel like the laws should change so
I understand the mindset of we were
walking away until the laws change it's
kind of like a protest sure and you
don't understand that sure like let's be
honest let's stop playing this game what
kind of men are walking away what kind
of men are walking away is there really
the men that women want they're really
attractive handsome successful men that
are walking away or is that really
what's going on or is it or is it a 23
year old virgin who can't have any sex
you say I'm walking away from women they
walked away from you first so my biggest
thing with some of this protesting is
who's protesting because it's so funny
because what happens is you have all
these guys on internet saying I don't do
relationships and I know them in person
and they have girlfriends they have
wives on the side they don't tell people
these things no one's walking away but
the foolish kids who are watching this
content online those guys not walking we
think they're living without women
anything don't have a relationship you
don't have any kids
walking away from no games no games
so so I know I'm saying like they're
walking away from marriage and you can
do that and you can see that because the
marriage rates are lower than lower 50
percent of women that hit 30 are single
and childless so so I I would who's
walking away are the billionaires
walking away from Marriage are there are
the are the heiresses walking away from
Marriage the first person that comes
into my head is Leonardo DiCaprio that
man is not married what about George
Clooney George Clooney come on we can we
we can go I'm not a big movie person I
just think towards Cooney's a big start
like we're not the character he's
he's no that's Tom Cruise that's the
topic I'm really I'm not trying to be
disingenuous I'm just really not a movie
my point is show me who's walking away
stop playing these games women don't
care about those guys are walking away
go go they're freaking red pill Randy
7x253 don't care about him walking away
come on man yeah those guys are they
will get married the rock is married
yeah LeBron James is married yeah Jay-Z
is married stop playing these games they
don't care about those guys you're not
protesting you think you're it's like
that fat girl who's like we're having a
sex protest the 300 pound book beluga
whales are having a sex protest and all
of a sudden the men are going to behave
themselves yeah right no one cares about
you protesting it's interesting I know
I've just met a lot of guys through the
show that have said like that they want
and I know you'll say maybe they're
capping I don't know but they don't want
to get married at least legally and I I
understand that like if you wouldn't
want to get married legally let me tell
you about those guys there was a time of
the day where there's a bunch of
feminists they were in their early 20s
and they would say we're we're not
having any kids the world's
overpopulated oh marriage is this we're
not having any children this day you
think they're the exact equivalent 100
exact equivalent and all of a sudden 35
years old you knock on that girl's door
hey Susie oh what's back there oh a face
those are my kids one two three yeah
three kids what happened to that
feminist stuff when the world's
overpopulated inside of her I mean I was
20 years old I feel you know it was just
you know I was in college I'm like oh
what my hair was blue it was just a
phase yeah see me in 10 years see my my
my play is 10 years right now people
don't realize I'm stopping putting out
content I'm actually slowing everything
down intentionally because in 10 years
it's gonna be time and 10 years what's
going to happen is we will see who is
right and who is wrong we will see how
many of these people who are saying I'm
never gonna get married we're gonna see
because right now we're in the era of
where everybody can say whatever they
want to say but then all of a sudden the
same way there was a time of the day
where to pick up artist Community what
the most prevalent community in today's
society and all of a sudden years later
it fell apart because it was not good
good for the Long Haul so my biggest
thing is that is let's play the 10-year
game and in 10 years we will see if I'm
a faker if I'm a liar if I'm deceitful
you will see it actually and I deserve
to be exposed and hung from the highest
cross but my biggest thing that we will
see and we will be able to figure out
that the guys who are lying who are
capping and they will see it later and
what breaks my heart is there's gonna be
a whole community of guys who are going
to follow these men to enter the Earth
and they're going to change their ways
at the end of the race and all of a
sudden the guys will be like what
happened the same way shout out to my
girl sham booty shambui said one of my
biggest regressors when I was in my 20s
I told women that I didn't want any kids
I don't want any kids I don't want any
kids and all of a sudden now I'm 35 I
have a bunch of kids I'm the happiest
person on planet Earth and it hurts me
because there were some women who took
my advice now they're never going to
have any kids because they're not 45 and
not like me who's going to be able to
have kids older or older in life so my
biggest thing is that when we're giving
people real life advice and real life
information we will see in 10 years how
much you live this life how much is this
for the content how much is this if
you're is this about what you genuinely
believe we will see in 10 years so what
what percent of red pill content
creators do you think actually live the
life that they say
to your point the challenge is
entertainment and the best comedy is
that office type comedy where you don't
know what's serious and what's not so to
me if if I was to look at their content
I would say maybe two three percent of
them two three percent if that live live
because to me I know it as a guy you can
be like man I tell women this and I tell
women that and I tell but deep man you
ain't doing that back home stop playing
it's just it's just talk but then it
might be a young guy who's like oh yeah
I'm gonna do it like that it's just talk
can I have an example huh I personally
uh-huh will not talk about anybody if
they are not in the room I will not no
you don't you can just be abroad you
don't have to say their name or anything
I just wanted I meant like an example of
a situation like that so here's the deal
like I said a lot of people tell me
stuff in private that I'm not gonna ever
shout out publicly but I'm Gonna Give
You examples there's guys who will tell
you I don't do relationships I don't do
it years later then you'll have a whole
girlfriend I don't do family then years
later they're married so to me you like
I said it's a this next tendency I I
I've been watching male content for so
long and I've seen how this stuff goes
and you just seeing how it plays I've
seen the cycle yeah I seen the dudes
that come on the scene and say this and
so Jordan I'm this and I'm that and then
use weight wait wait guys wait let's see
how his life really turns out you know
oh my gosh another one this is another
cycle to me and it breaks my heart
because if what I love that you said is
this entertainment keep it 100 It's
Entertainment and you are also trying to
help but it's primarily for
entertainment so don't act like you
really believe all these ideas
everything that you're communicating to
these men stop acting like you genuinely
believe all these things because you
don't and let's keep it 100 I would
never be if the red pill simply said is
all of our opinions a lot of his jokes
is we're not really serious about most
of this stuff some of it we are some of
it we believe but most of it is just a
little funny I would have no problems
whatsoever but when you say we are the
truth come on man don't don't let's not
let's not do this don't let's not
deceive these men I won't be see these
Men Please Don't deceive these men these
are real life human beings and their
real lives lives and their children's
life and their grandchildren's lives
that are at stake like you said it's a
serious problem going on in today's
world let's not play around with these
men it is a matter of life and death in
the tongue do not play with these men
and their lives and their legacies I
refuse to do that so what are solutions
to you then so I love your question
solution number one
is we need to build up stronger more
competent powerful men who are assertive
who have boundaries who are respectful
who are financially stable who are
physically fit who are emotionally
healthy who are spiritually grounded we
need well-rounded men who not only have
all the skills that make women happy but
also have all the skills to make a woman
horny we need those men not just these
you know these nice guy Weenie Hut
Juniors who are doormats
actually I've never I didn't know as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible